when it comes to rollerblading ain't
nothing he can't do with a guitar
that's why ain't nobody never been able
to pick up these styles and things that
i got
i'm robert billboard walker
and i'm a legend of the blue
[Music]
i always from a little boy on up i
always wanted to be looked at i want
everybody looking at me i wanted to be
one of the guys that everybody said
there he is
that's what inspired me to really make
me want to be a musician
the cool thing about bilbo walker is
that he grew up in the same mississippi
delta blues environment as like charlie
patton or robert johnson or muddy waters
or holland wolf or bb king and when he
performs it feels like that is like a
living fossil
this is one of the light city
it's not radar nightclub it's more like
a a jug joint it's what the people love
down in mississippi
it's out there in the boonies not even a
town it's just out in a field
and i also love the fact that it's just
so hard to find
right till you're at it
i didn't want to open in town because
town they got too many roof out here we
ain't got no roof from the ground up
from the stretch that's right we built
in here and put it on the ground
it's an old army barracks quonset hut
cut in pieces moved onto his property
himself a real authentic juke joint is
going to be african-american-owned
because it comes out of that culture and
it's going to probably have a big
personality behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
this is seven years i've been on this
thing
but it wouldn't have took that long but
it kept getting robbed and dead floyd
come in got it
you got nothing in this place that makes
you won't just want to give up
then i got ambition about everything
inside i said now i'm going i'm gonna
give it one more chance
[Music]
real juke joints that are still
operating with live music i can probably
count on one hand
i used to say you know you're just
you're not going to get any more joints
like that i would have to say bilbo's
just gets grandfathered in it's just
such a real thing and it's kind of an
extension of him and sort of what he's
been doing his whole life
[Music]
i wanted to be something that people
remember me for
see in order to make people love you
like that you got to be different
i wanted to come as famous as any place
ever been in the world
[Music]
you